- So this past September,
a dream was realized
when the Academy Museum of
Motion Pictures opened its doors.
A museum like this comes
with a hefty price tag,
482 million dollars.
And I know many people in
this room donated generously.
I did my part, and this weekend,
this past weekend, I paid a visit
to see where my $15 went.
(audience laughing)
(dramatic music)
Barbara Streisand Bridge.
Wonder how much she donated to get this.
I knew I should've went up to 25 bucks.
- Excuse me, can I help you?
- Yeah, I'm here to see my stuff.
- Oh, the ticket booth is right over here.
- I'm Wanda Sykes.
I'm a donor.
- What level?
- 15 big ones.
- 15,000?
Oh, Ms. Sykes.
- That's tax deductible, right?
I know some of these people.
- That's our donor wall.
Okay, come on in.
- Ah, go ahead, I'll,
I'll catch up with you.
(audience laughing)
- [Tom] This is one of
our most popular exhibits.
- Oh, you ain't gotta
tell me what this is.
Billy Porter, Kinky Boots.
Originally, it was called
Kinky Kitten Heels.
- They're the ruby slippers.
- Tom, you got this whole
room for the "Wizard of Oz,"
and this is the only thing
you got from "The Wiz?"
Wait, I got this.
(audience laughing)
You ever been to Meryl Streep's house?
- Mm-mm.
- Looks just like this.
(audience laughing)
- This is a very important display.
Hattie McDaniel was the
first Black Oscar winner.
Her award went missing after
she donated it to a university.
- DeVry?
(audience laughing)
- And this empty case
honors her historic win.
- It also honors all the
Oscars won by Black directors.
- I'm sure you will recognize
this famous Oscar gown
worn by-
- Little Richard.
- Cher.
- In 1986, when she
presented at the Oscars,
but didn't receive a nomination.
- Ah see, this is what you wear
when you break up with Oscar.
This is like the ultimate revenge gown.
'Cause it says, "You could've had this.
"You could've had all this."
(audience laughing)
- Everything in this room
belongs to Mr. Spike Lee.
- Wait a minute, he just left it here?
How much y'all charging him for storage?
- The Academy isn't
charging Mr. Lee anything.
- Wait a minute, he
stores it here for free?
Okay, I gotta get in on this,
'cause I'm paying 250 out in Glendale.
(audience laughing)
Is it 24-hour access?
(intriguing music)
- Ooh, white chicks.
That Marlon Wayans was hilarious.
- This is from-
- "Aquaman," Jason Momoa.
- No, this is Guillermo
del Toro's creature
from "The Shape of Water."
- Well, you didn't see Jason Momoa
after filming all day underwater.
(audience chuckling)
Hey, Harvey Weinstein.
(audience laughing)
- Here we have film
history with over 700 films
from the Lumiere brothers to present day.
- You know, they have monitors
like this at Best Buy.
You pick the one you want,
and they load it right into your car.
I'm gonna take this one.
Come grab an end.
(audience laughing)
- No, no, no, Ms. Sykes.